by majo my name is yong tan from the
university of
nottingham i'm currently a research
assistant professor
working on a project understanding the
mechanisms
on the host and packaging interactions
in the context of mycobacterium
tuberculosis infection
today i will talk about any models for
tuberculosis research before i started
the talk
i would like to thank the conference
organizers
for giving me this great opportunity so
i may share my expertise with the
colleagues across the world
tuberculosis is airborne disease caused
by
mycobacterium tuberculosis mycobacterium
tuberculosis
is an intracellular pathogen it's mainly
in fact
macrophages in the lung and survival and
lubricates in macrophages tuberculosis
is currently
ranked as top of ten causes of deaths in
the world
above hiv and the malaria
according to the who report
one third of a global population has
been infected by microbacterium
tuberculosis
among those infected 5 to 10
of people will develop active tb
sometime
during their lifetime the remaining 90
percent of infected people
will have latent tb infection in
2016 of 10 million people
had active tb because of tb infection
leading to 1.7 million deaths
including 0.4 million co-infected by hiv
tuberculosis is a leading killer of
hiv-positive people
in 2016 40 of hiv
deaths were caused by tb infection
tb is a poverty related disease
a number of factors must facilitate the
tb
spread the first factor is poorly
ventilated and overcrowded living and
working condition
which may provide ideal conditions for
tb
spread the second factor is more
nutrition and other diseases
particularly hiv which may reduce body
resistance to tb
infection the third factor is limited
access to health care
it has been estimated let one person
with achieve the tb
may pass tb onto 10 to 15 people
annually based on who report
over 95 of tb deaths occurs in low
income and middle income countries
this map shows you the global tb
epidemics
here we can see tb cases mainly
happens in the south and east asia
under sahara areas these two regions
account for over 85 percent of tb cases
in the world
seven countries including india
pakistan indonesia philippines
china nigeria and south africa
they are high tb berlin countries they
account for a total
65 of her global tb cases
in 2016.
in most cases tb is a suitable
infestation
however compared to the treatment for
the infectious days
the treatment for a tb may take six
months
after two years this table shows you the
recommended combination treatment for tb
sensitive for the drug sensitive tb
it includes a eight weeks intensive
treatment with four antibiotics
isolated leukemia pilar xenomites
and ethanbutor followed by 18 weeks
continuing treatment with ison acid and
luthempin
the treatment rate success rate for drug
sensitive tb
is quite high it's over 85 percent
in the world in 2016. these two books
usual
led four different recombinant
combination treatments for genesis tv
here we can see the efficacy of
achievement can change based on a
different combination
in the contrast to central sensitivity
jack resistant to be especially modular
resistant tb and extremely drug
resistance tb
is becoming a public health crisis and
health security
threat double ho estimated
there were 600 000 new cases
with resistance to the revamping the
most effective
nttp drugs with the first line and tb
jags
of which around half million
had multi-junk resistant tb
the treatment for revamping resistant tb
and
muscular disease tb is longer with more
expensive and toxic drugs
there are treatment regimens recommended
by double ho
for drug resistant tb it will last
for over 20 months or even longer time
the latest data reported through who
showed
a treatment success rate for multiple
reasons tb
is around fifty percent only
thirty percent for extremely
drug-resistant tv
as i imagined above
tuberculosis is album disease it's
caused by macrobacterium tuberculosis
these slides show you the pathogenic
life cycle of microbial tuberculosis in
the host
aerosol particles containing
mycobacterial cells
is covered up by a patient with
negativity
and uptake by the neural host the
bacteria is deposited
in the lower lamp of the new host and
recruit
the macrophages to the inflation site
these macrophages may become
infected by magnetic tuberculosis and
initiate a
new run of macrophage recruitment in la
lamb
form the glandulomas lagonilomas is a
well-organized
aggregate of cells these cells include
differentiated
macrophages and lymphocytes in the early
stage of infection
the granulomas may facilitate
macrophageal growth and expand the
infection
by allowing the bacteria to infect new
allying macrophages
as the development of adaptive
immunity in the new host the granuloma
may reject metabacterial growth or
survival in the host
however under certain conditions
macrophage inaccurate may undergo
necrosis
to form necrotic core uniqueness
the necrotic core may facilitate
bacterial growth
and transmission to the new host
fuller tb diagnosis led to
a traditional method one's macrobacteria
culture
the second one is as the fasting name
for the tb patient's
sputum the left picture shows euler
morphology of the bacterial colony on
the aggar plates
this is where um the
patients spinton was placed on their 7h
11 agar plates the
right figure shows you the acid the
fastest thing for the tb patient
sputon here we can see this pink large
bacteria
this is a metal bacterial cells
this slide shows you another um
sample of the pathology analysis
for tb patient alarm here we can see
the cavity in the lung of tb patient
methylene granuloma we also concealer
this cascading granuloma lesion
in the lung of two patients under chest
x-array analysis we can see a light
region in the tb patient's lung when
compared to the health
individual
in a typical diagnosis we also wanted to
know what is the
histopathological outcome in the lung of
chip patient
this slide shows you other
histopathological analysis
for tb patient lung samples
in a tb patient example we can see a
typical guanoloma
this kulin luma contained a central core
of necrotic lipid rich material
surrounds the bifurman macrophages
epithelial microphages
and the lymph sides the
big pictures on the first row shows you
three
examples of casca 18 granulomas
found in a tb patient lamp the fig
a on the first row shows a early casca
18 granulomas
in the lamp over people with immediate
tuberculosis
the figure b on the first row
shows you a cluster of cas18 granulomas
here we can see a typical necrotic core
surrounded by
macrophages and the lymph sides
the frequency on the first row shows a
old lesion in a human lung
here we can see a fibrous capsule
and a necrotic center
the fig a on the second law here shows
you another example
we can find in a tb patient we can see
the cavity formation here
um we just imagine you know granulomas
in the tb patient
lamb um so we wanted to know uh how the
edge of the granulomas
looks like uh the figure b on the second
law shows you the
ph staining and further
tb patient lump suggestions here we can
see on edge of granulomas they are
fibrosis we also can see these illusions
filled by the lymph sites and
macrophages
while tuberculosis research is not
vaccine available has been used for
almost 100 years old
since 1921 the efficacy
of ambovia's obesity wins over time
after vaccination it has been fun
bcg has no or little protection against
the primary tb
in adolescents under adults additionally
bcd is not recommended for hiv
positive infants because of high risk of
determination pcg infection
the second issue is tb treatment
as i mentioned above more and more
drug-resistant
is found in the world so the new jackets
or regimens
are urgently required to clear jack
resistant tv
we also need new jackets or regimens to
shorten the treatment saturation
i mentioned about even for a jack
sensitive tv it will take us six months
it's a long time it will increase the um
the check sensitive tb the jack
using the tb percentage
in the tb patient solar new gentleman's
a new drug and achievement may be needed
to shorten their
uh treatment duration for the both
jagged sensitivity
tb and the drug resistant tb we also
need
new jackets with low toxicity and
high efficacy the third issue is the tb
diagnosis
for the current tb diagnosis see we use
metabolic culture as the fasting
stinging as i mentioned above
we also have a pcr-based and
elastase-based diagnosis
we also have a skin test for a tb
however there is no efficient tb and
tools we can use
to discriminate latent infection and
active tb infection
so we need to efficient biomarker
so we can use it to efficiently
discriminate based on tb and additive tv
the inner human we also needed a bar
marker
we can use it to determine treatment
outcome
as i mentioned for the tv treatment is a
long-term duration
so we need to have a biomarker we can
determine
the treatment outcome but not use the
bacterial culture
as a in this case we may decrease the
opportunity for drug-resistant tb
occurrence
the tuberculosis research will help us
to understand the pathogenesis of
microplatinum tuberculosis
we also we also help us to understand
the host defense mechanisms
in the context of microbiota and
tuberculosis infection
the tuberculosis study will also help us
to
develop new tb diagnosis tools new
magazine and the new ndtv
jags and arrangements
animal studies is necessary in a tv
research
this slide shows you the current
available animal models it has been used
in a tv research they include
different species of mice rabbit
green pig zebra fish and monkey
the monkey is a non-human private animal
model in activity research
to mimic the progress of a tb infection
tb patient
is necessary for animal models to
develop
human-like granulomas in the lung
for both rabbits and a greeny pig
a human microneedlomas can be found in
the lung after
mtb infection here we concealer necrotic
core
in aquanulomas from both rabbits and the
green pig
alarm we also can see this necrotic coil
is surrounded by
macrophages and lymphocytes however
in early study it was found that when
eulermas formed in the
mtb infected mice there's no necrotic
core
additionally the bacteria is mischiefed
in the macrophages it's not released
to the extracellular environment as we
find in the
tb patient granuloma we
also can see a typical necrotic core
in a granulomas here we can see the
nuclear core
surrounded by the macrophages and
lymphocytes
so this is a typical structure of
granuloma as we can see
in a tb patient
we can see from this fig a here i just
mentioned it's a typical
tb granulomas we can find
inner monkey after drug treatment
a healing granuloma characterized by a
central area
containing raster epithelial microphages
with prominent features of involving
fibrous pressure
can be found in the lung of monkey
it provides a very good model for a drug
study
to develop new nttb juggers and their
regimens
other type of granulomas or illusions
also can be found
in the lamb of monkey of the dragon
treatment the frequency here
can show you a poorly circumscribed
areas of interstellar
fibrosis with and without prominent
area of cellularity in lumps of monkeys
after drug treatment
so this one is also the kind of
revolution after juggling treatment more
similar to healing granulomas
the figure d here shows you a another
example we can see
in the monkey so this is a fibrous
pacific granulomas with a central area
of mineralization surrounded by
prominent peripheral fibrosis
so the monkey provides very good
animal models so we can use to develop
anti-tb drugs even ndtv vaccine
in an animal study for tv
list one question is how we determine
which animal models we need
in a study this table partially
provides provides a guideline to ask
how to select animal models in a tv
research
here we can see in rabbits guinea pig
and the non-human planet we can see
the development of necrosis in a
granuloma also like has
aging and cavitation
in the lung after mtb infection there's
no
cavitation can be found in the mouse
model
also therefore very rare cascading can
be found
in atmos after mtp investing and
no necrosis however
because of small size cost effective
and availability of immunological agents
mouse are still widely used as
mouse model in achieving research
more recently a new mod model has
attracted the attention of scientists in
a
tb field in this model
in this mass model we can find
three different types of granulomas
after mtb infection
and this mouse mod is called c3heb
fg they contain two different mouse
backgrounds
one is the c3heb another one feg
background um these
three different type of granulomas i can
show you here
they're for the type 1 when granulomas
we also call the type 1 lesion here
most similar to classic human tb
granulomas
in which liver solid encapsulated
cases necrotic lesion these lesions
become evident 35 to 45 days
after low dose mtb infection
in a this lesions
is originated as a focal accumulation of
fermi macrophages
interspersed with nutrients often
prosimile to blockers
the peripheral margins containing
abundant loosely aggregated epithelioid
microphages
interspersed with a small number of
scattered lymphocytes
the type 2 lesions is
similar to a regularly progressive
pneumonia composed almost entirely of
neutrophils
over time majority of the type 2 lesions
had
substantial increase in size and contain
a central region
of cascading necrosis
the central region had evidence of
cellular necrosis and cell death
and over time it will be a similar to
the
type 1 lesion the type 3
lesion in a c3heb fj
mice were cellular inflammatory lesions
that were indiscretionable from
pulmonary lesions
typically found a bubble say in the
brexit smiles
the policy and the plague system is what
widely used as
animal model in achieving research
this slide shows you the correlation
between the bacterial numbers
with their gross pathology over
granuloma in a lamb here we can see the
high number
here we can see the high number
of the bacteria in the lung they
cause a much bigger granulomas in a
muslim however
in the low bacterial number the size of
granulomas
is much smaller
as i mentioned above tb is spread
through the air from present to present
the tiny water particles containing the
metabacteria may be
expelled into the air when a person with
infested tb of the lumps
the cough's sneeze speaks even singer
can spread the tv to a new host
therefore
specific personal protective equipment
and laboratory is needed for tb
research
for the animal studies of tuberculosis
bs bsl3 facility is necessary
to mimic the natural infection root
of tb in human animals are infected
and grossly so this is a recommended
infection root
for tb research
this slide shows you the aerosol
infection device
it is one of the popular
device in achieving research this is a
glass
core inheriting exposure system it may
generate
aerosolized bacteria and infect mice
the instrument consists of a
large circular tank this is also called
aerosol chamber
that contains a circular um
basket with five pipe compartments for
animals
so this is a five pipe shift compartment
basket the aerosol chamber has a heavy
lead with a heavy lid with four locking
handles
let's lock the lid tightly against the
heavy
duty gasket gasket the lid also has two
uv lamps under its underside
and these lamps come on during the
decontamination cycle of instrument
operation
the front of the instrument contains
a contour panel with four timers for the
various cycles of
operation and two air flow meters and
two air control knobs and the three
holes with the clamps used to attach the
nebulizer when the instrument is in
operation
compressed air is flowing through the
nebulizer
and produce a very fine mix of the
bacterial suspension
which is is then carried by a large
volume of air
flow into the aerosol chamber here
this fire mist is name is caught by
animals within
the basket
after the airflow path through the
chambers
the airflow then exits the chamber
through two hepa filters and a
superheated exhaust stack
this is an exhaust stack the
where the air is subsequently
incinerated before release
so in this case we can remove all the
bacterial particles
before release to the air after the
nebulization
process the machine runs a cloud
decay process in which the
aerosol chambers is purged with fresh
air
this may also help enjoying any bacteria
attached to the fur of animals a surface
of baskets
and their chambers a final step is a
uv light treatment
in which the uv lamp handler lid
comes on and decontaminates the top
surface of the basket
except the techniques we used to
infatiomize
exactly is exhibited one we mentioned on
a previous slide
there's also other techniques we can use
including
intravenous injection and respiratory
injection intravenous injection
can be finished through the tailwind
or retro-orbital sinus
further respiratory roots infection
we can infect mice using
interchange injection or international
infection
for injection injection the bacteria is
injecting to the lung of
mice directly
recently we developed a new technique
for engine chair care injection
this slide shows you the assembling of
this
injection system there are three main
components
in this system one is the installation
and platform the sec the second one is
the
illuminator this adjustable illuminator
so we used to
look like it the czechie of mice
the third is the glass desiccator
we first used 3d printer technique
to generate the main part of
installation platform
here the 3d printer technique
is based on a process called additive
manufacturing
this technique a 3d print technique
is becoming more and more important
right now
to create custom designed or sometimes
difficult to manufacture
products the file for this
platform is available online it's free
for everyone you can find a link for
this file
in our paper
after we have released this platform we
also generated two different
metal bars once a crossbar with mouse
inside the hanger the settings
adjustment
metal bar we first insert crossbar into
the
main part of the installation platform
and insert the
adjustment bar into the one of the three
holes
in a platform so we can adjust
the height of the crossbar according to
the size of
animals in a study
um after we have this system assembled
after we have this system assembled
um we need to prepare mice so we can
synchronize
and we use inhalation is referring to
anesthetized mice in a heavy glass
desiccator as i assume
he as i am shown here a glass test
heater
the mice were then monitored to ensure
sufficient
depth of anesthesia
after the mice is ready for injection
each mouse
was gently suspended by its superior
incisors on the mouse inside the hanger
and its body placed on to the slot
on the bevel places a slot on the bevel
of
the platform thus got
arc adjustable illuminator with a double
goose neck
was positioned near the pharyngeal
epiglottic
region of the mouth neck the tongue
of the mouth was gently pulled out
to the left side using small jesus and
the lamb
pushed down with a micro spatula
the check here was visualized
by a perky 10 years transient
chance illumination using the lights
imaged from the end of a gooseneck
fiberoptic end
thirty to fifty percent of samples this
is a bacterial suspension
were gently injected into the lamp by
interchangeable
injection using appendage research um
pipette
and geoloading tips
after injection the mice were wrapped
with a clean paper towel and
and returned back to their new cage
mice were monitored until they were
fully recovered from
another seizure the fig e
here shows you the yield of bacteria in
lamb
and one day after injection here we can
see
90 of bacteria is injected into the lung
of mice efficiently
to determine the bacterial numbers of
burdens
in the different organs the organ can be
homogenized using
hand operated tissue grinder here's
usually
a glass hand operated tissue grinder
we also can use electronic
power a grinder um
we should be careful when you use the
these two um
tissue grinder and these experiments
should be
done in the passivity cabinet
the homogenization process may generate
significant
aerosol hazard so the uh
glass bogus connected to the safety
cabinet is highly recommended especially
for
especially for electronic power grinder
next question is what essay we can do or
perform
in an animal study for tuberculosis we
can look at
the bacterial input of burden in a
different organs
by the bacterial culture on the other
plates or
use as the fascinating for the organ
sections
we also can look at histopathological
change in the organ some
samples using he staining or
immunostaining
other experiments we can do is we can
perform
flow cytometry like the fluid cytometry
rtpcr
even angry sequencing elasta to look at
the immuno
immunological uh change or response
in the tissue after emitting infection
flow cytometry can be used to determine
different populations of immune cells
after mtb infection
and see which population of immune cells
is
important to kill bacteria of
facilitated bacterial growth
in a tissue rtpcr can be used to
determine specific
host or unleashed in a tissue
only sequencing is a more powerful
technique
it can be used to determine a host or
micro bacterial gene expression profile
in a certain tissue after mtb infection
elasta is used to determine the subkin
or katakan production
in a tissue we also can use the blood
samples from
mtb infected animals you know using this
blood sample we can
look at the different holsters proteins
such as the subtitles
and we also can look at the peripheral
profile of
blood cells in a whole blood of animals
to determine which and which
cell type is important to cure bacteria
in a tv biomarker study we can
look at the specific biomarkers we can
use to
diagnosis tv in the future
in a anti-tb drug study
we can look at the general stability in
an
animal blood in this case we may develop
more effective or stable ndtv drugs
the tuberculosis research is important
today
as i mentioned but it will help us to
understand the bacterial pathogenesis
uh in a host and also understand the
host unique and
adaptive immunity response to mtb
infection
the study will help us to develop new or
more
effective tb vaccine and anti-tb
drugs and regimens also help us to find
a new tb
diagnosis to us
and the final goal of our tb research is
to contribute to the
global tb contour and finally find the
solution
to enter the tv in the world
and finally i would thank you
for your attention i'll be very happy to
take any questions
thank you dr chang for that informative
presentation
we will now start the lab q a portion of
the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question drop
down box located
on the far left of your presentation
window type your questions into the box
that appears on your screen
and click the send button we'll answer
as many of your questions
as we have time for let's get started
our first question
is how to measure how do you measure
microbacterium numbers in a stock used
in infection
it's a good question we do need to know
the bacterial numbers in a stock
the list will be used for the infection
um to determine the concentration of a
bacteria in a stock
macrobacterial suspension this which we
get from the
stock is diluted in pbs in a 10-foot
series and the name
plated on 7h10 or 7h11 agar plates
the bacteria colonies are counted three
to
four weeks after incubated at 37 degree
before we start the experiment the oil
stock is
the stock is stored at mass 80.
thank you for the answer our next
question is
how many mice may be infected once using
glass coal aerosol device
and is any anesthesia region needed
in one cycle up to 80 to
100 miles maybe infected when we use a
basket with
five pie shaped compartments as shown on
the slide
but sometimes we also can use a smaller
basket in this case we
in fact less mice in an
infection no anesthesia agent
is needed
thank you okay it looks like we have
time for one more question
the last question is how does glasgow
inhalation system get
decontaminated post-infection and
sterilize the airflow before release
during the experiment
this is a excellent protein because the
acidity is always the first concern for
the researchers
when we work on a tuberculosis so
when we use the glass core system so
there are different steps we can
decontaminate the first is during the
infection
before release into the air the airflow
is passed
through the two hepa filters and
then a superheated exhaust stack that is
incinerated and industrial particles as
i mentioned on the slide
the second is that after infection
there is a cloud decay step
in which the chamber is approached with
the flash air
we can remove any elastic bacteria on
the fur of animals in the surface of the
basket
and a chamber after this step
these layers treatments with the uv
light as i mentioned this uv light is
under the leaves on the underside
of the lid and this uv line
is comes on let me decontaminate
the top surface of the basket the third
is after infection
finished the nebulizer and the plastic
basket will be removed from the air
russell device
and auto clipped the surface of the
chambers
um is decontaminated using dean's fatent
thanks